they were three brothers raised in
manchester
two of them took a path which caused
death and destruction
in the city they called home today
ishmael the older brother of salman and
hashim abadi
responsible for the manchester arena
attack spoke out
for the first time for the 22 killed and
dozens more injured
he had this message i want to apologize
on behalf of my family to the victims
for all the pain hashim and salman
caused would you give me your full name
and date of birth please
yesterday his younger brother hashim the
only person convicted for this atrocity
was sentenced to life in prison he'll
have to serve
at least 55 years behind bars ishmael
wanted to stay well away i'm glad this
happened he said
because i can put it all behind me get
on with my life
and look after my family he added i had
no idea my brothers had taken this path
ismail left the family home in 2013 he
since been married and has a child
but said he was still close to his
brothers i spoke to salman the night
before the attack
he seemed calm quite normal there was no
indication he'd do anything like this
but the following day on the 22nd of may
salman abadi murdered 22 people and left
many physically
and mentally scarred hours after the
attack
ishmael was arrested by counter-terror
police he was questioned for two weeks
before released without charge the past
three years have been hell he said
i've lost two brothers and my family is
ripped apart because of it
but what happened has happened i can't
stop it i can't go back
it's done and dusted his apology today
will bring little comfort to those who
continue to live with the aftermath
of this brutal attack intimate rasheed
sky news in manchester